[موسيقى]
عندما يقول الناس إنها منطقة حرب وكذلك
منطقة حرب في منطقة حرب
معارك
كاتانا الأمريكية.
ضابط بالقوات وطبيب بيطري في الحرب في جمهورية كوريا ، لقد رأيت هذه
الخيمة تنتشر معي بالفعل عندما
كنا في بلد عندما كنا في العراق الآن
، وقد قام ببنائها على أرض أمريكية
للتعامل مع سحق من التعامل مع الحالات التي
لم يعد مستشفاه لديه مكان
لتكييف الهواء  خيام في
حرارة الصحراء المكونة من ثلاثة أرقام للتعامل مع
المريض بعد المريض El Centro هي
مقاطعة إمبراطورية تقع على الحدود الأمريكية المكسيكية ،
هذا المجتمع الريفي 85 ٪
لاتيني واحد من كل أربعة يعيش في فقر
للفرد الواحد لديه ثلاثة أضعاف عدد
حالات كوفاك  نظرًا لأن لوس أنجلوس ومعدل الوفيات
هو الأعلى في كاليفورنيا ، فهل من
المخيف بالنسبة لك أنك طبيب
تعمل في خيمة في أمريكا ،
نعم إنه أمر لا يصدق ، أليس كذلك؟
هل هو أكثر المرضى مرضًا في وحدة العناية المركزة ،
فكل مريض في وحدة العناية المركزة
المكونة من 12 سريرًا لديه Kovac 11 منهم نجوا مع
أجهزة التنفس الصناعي ، هل يمكنك شرح ما
ترتديه جيدًا إنه جهاز يساعد في
الحفاظ على كل ما تعرفه مثل
البرد ، لذلك نحن لسنا  تتعرض لأي شيء
هو ما تحتاجه الممرضة آمبر مارا
للبقاء بأمان أثناء مساعدة مريضها
البالغ من العمر 40 عامًا كم هو
مريض حقًا وهو صغير حقًا لذلك
نحاول أن نفعل كل ما في وسعنا
قبل أن نقوم بتنبيبه
ما يوحي بذلك  بالنسبة لك
كممرضة ، فأنا فقط أعتقد أن
الكثير من الناس لا يكرمون مثل هذا
اليوم في المنزل ، كما تعلمون أن الكثير من الأشخاص
يقومون بالتواصل الاجتماعي ولا يقومون
بالتباعد الاجتماعي وهذا ما يقوم به قسم الإطفاء المركزي
يرى في الشارع غالبًا
أن يصبح قائد الكتيبة
يقول في هذه المدينة التي يبلغ عدد سكانها 50000 شخص
كل ساعة ، نعم ، هناك
مريض غيبوبة محتمل في مكان الحادث ، لذا في هذه المرحلة
، يستعد موظفونا
لمريض غيبوبة في ساعة كاملة  كابتن بدلة Azmat ،
تشاد ويتلوك ، ينعش
مريضًا فاقدًا للوعي ، إنها درجة حرارة خانقة 110
درجة ، يجب أن تكون عميقًا على جميع
المعدات وتزيل كل زينا الرسمي
والاستحمام ووضع زي موحد مختلف ،
نعم سيدتي ، نحن ننهي الجميع
متعبًا حقًا والجميع  يمكن أن أرى في
وجهي ، أشعر بالإحباط من وصول كابتن المريض
ويتلوك إلى غرفة الطوارئ الطبية المركزية في Elle ،
لقد وصلنا إلى السعة التي نقلناها
إلى ضعف أو ثلاثة أضعاف العدد الطبيعي من
المرضى الذين نرسلهم على ما أعتقد
في  في الشهرين الماضيين ، أرسلنا
ما يقرب من خمسمائة مريض ،
بعضهم إلى سان دييغو المجاورة ، والبعض الآخر
بعيدًا مثل شمال كاليفورنيا ، هذه
المروحية هنا لالتقاط
مريض آخر في غرفة الطوارئ ، يقوم الأطباء والممرضات بوضع
أنبوب تحت هذا الستارة الزرقاء للحد من
التعرض للجسيمات ، واستقرت رؤوس المرضى.
لماذا يحدث هذا بشكل سيء للغاية
هنا قوة إمبريالية هناك الكثير
من مواطني الولايات المتحدة الذين يعيشون في مكسيكالي
، وكان لديهم تفشي سيئ حقًا
هناك الكثير من
الأشخاص الذين يعبرون الحدود هنا للعمل الذين يعيشون في مكسيكالي ثم يأتون ويعملون هنا ، ترسل الحقول في مقاطعة إمبريال المنتجات عبر البلاد وحتى في حالة حدوث جائحة ، يدخل حوالي 20000 عامل مكسيكي يوميًا بشكل قانوني كل صباح لتوفير العمالة ، لا عمل لا نقود للحصول على طعام يقول عامل مزرعة جاسينتو مورينو البالغ من العمر 65 عامًا ، توفي أربعة من زملائه من عمال المزارع بسبب COBIT ، وهو يقول إنه لا يمكننا الفوز في حرب على الكوفات في غرفة الطوارئ ، انظر إلى الصورة الكبيرة التي نحتاجها لخوض الحرب على COBE حيث تتكاثر وهذا إن منطقتنا في مقاطعة كولفين ثنائية القومية ليست المرض ، إنها الأعراض التي يتعرضون لها من المحددات الاجتماعية للصحة مثل وضع الطعام على الطاولة مثل الاضطرار إلى العمل في ظروف خطرة مثل عدم وجود قناع ، نحن الملصق لتلك التفاوتات والسبب في أننا ليس بمقدورنا السيطرة على كوفيتش ، فالمستشفى هنا يستعد لما لم يأت بعد. هذه الخيمة الفارغة هي جناح COBIT المستقبلي ، هل هذه الخيمة علامة على أن هذا الوباء
ic هنا لأبقى نعم ، لذا فأنا أقول للناس انظروا الآن إنه جائحة في النهاية سيكون وباءً ، فهل هذه حقًا هي الطريقة التي نريد أن نعتني بها بمجتمعاتنا والإجابة هي لا